Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans
ScienceClic, les fluides supercritiques.
La matière peut exister sous différents états.
Dans notre quotidien, à la surface de la Terre,
ces états sont au nombre de trois.
Solide, liquideet gaz.
Chacune de ces trois formes
correspondà une certaine configuration microscopique.
Dansun solide,
les molécules sont fixées les unes par rapport aux autres,
elles respectent une structurerégulière,
car elles sont fortement liées.
Dans un liquide, les molécules sont liées
plus faiblement,et elles sont ainsi libres de se déplacer,
mais tout en gardant une certaine cohésion.
Unliquide peut donc se déformer
de façon fluide, mais il conserve un certain volume.
Contrairementaux gaz, dans lesquels
les molécules sont libres de leur mouvement,
et qui épousent alors levolume
tout entier dans lequel ils sont contenus.
En fonction de la température
et dela pression du milieu qui l’entoure,
un corps va se manifester
naturellementsous l’un de ces états.
Par exemple, sous la pression atmosphérique,
et pour unetempérature entre 0 et 100 degrés Celsius,
l’eau se trouve naturellement à l’état liquide.
Cesont les conditions que réunit notre atmosphère,
et c’est pour cette raison qu’on peut
trouver del’eau liquide sur la planète.
Mais pour cette même pression,
si la température de l’eau est de 200°C,
alors celle-ci sera naturellement
à l’état de gaz, de la vapeur d’eau.
Dans l’optique deschématiser les conditions
nécessaires à la présence de chacun des trois états,
onpeut réaliser ce qu’on appelle un diagramme de phase.
Un tel diagramme représente la phasede l’eau,
c'est-à-dire tout simplement l’état
dans lequel elle se trouve naturellement,
pourdifférentes valeurs de pression et de température.
On commence par se munir d’un récipient bienhermétique,
dans lequel on va placer de l’eau.
La température dans notre récipient peut être
réglée en le chauffant ou en le refroidissant,
et la pression peut être modifiée à l’aide
d’unpiston qui va appuyer ou tirer sur la paroi.
Pour remplir le diagramme,
on va se munir de troiscouleurs.
Par exemple, on peut choisir du gris pour l’état de gaz,
du bleu ciel pour l’étatliquide,
et du bleu foncé pour l’état solide.
En chaque point du diagramme, on associe
unecertaine température, et une certaine pression,
qu’on va venir régler directement sur lerécipient.
Une fois le réglage fait, on observe la phase
dans laquelle se trouve l’eau àl’intérieur du récipient,
et on peut alors placer un petit carré
sur le diagramme, dont la couleurreprésente cet état.
En répétant ce procédé pour de multiples valeurs,
on obtient finalementune sorte de carte,
sur laquelle apparaissent trois zones.
Pour comprendre, si la pressionet la température
sont telles qu’on se trouve dans l’une de ces zones,
par exemple la zonebleue foncée,
cela signifie que dans de telles
conditions de pression et de température,
l’eause trouve naturellement sous sa forme solide.
Une des premières choses qui saute aux yeux
estle fait que les trois zones sont délimitées entre elles
par des courbes bien spécifiques.
Lorsqu’onse trouve à la jonction entre deux zones,
alors les phases qui sont de part et d’autre
decette ligne peuvent coexister toutes les deux,
ensemble, de façon stable.
Par exemple,
lorsqu’on va chauffer un glaçon, sous la pression atmosphérique,
on va progressivement
se déplacer vers la droite du diagramme,
car sa température augmente.
Au moment oùon atteint la limite
de la zone solide, pour une température de 0°C,
les toutespremières gouttes
d’eau apparaissent sous forme liquide.
Progressivement, le glaçon vafondre,
tout en restant à la même température.
L’énergie qu’on lui fournit en chauffant,
n’estplus utilisée pour augmenter sa température,
mais pour le faire fondre, c'est-à-direpour réarranger
et séparer ses molécules, à l’échelle microscopique.
Une fois la transitionterminée,
lorsque le glaçon a entièrement fondu,
sa température va pouvoir augmenter de nouveau,
et on passe alors dans la zone
du diagramme qui correspond à l’état liquide.
On a effectuéce qu’on appelle une transition de phase,
on est passé d’un état de la matière à un autre,
en traversant l’une de ces courbes séparatrices.
Une autre remarque intéressante consiste
àobserver qu’il existe un point sur lequel se touchent les trois zones.
Ce point sur lediagramme est directement
en contact avec chacun des états de la matière,
solide, liquide etgaz.
Si on se place dans de telles conditions
de température et de pression,
il est ainsi possiblede faire coexister
à la fois de l’eau sous forme solide, liquide, et gazeuse.
On appelle ce point,bien particulier, le point triple.
Dans le cas de l’eau, ce point triple
correspond à une pressionde 0,6% d’atmosphère,
et à une température de 1 centième de °C.
Ce sont des conditions quine sont
pas naturellement réunies sur Terre,
mais si on les applique en laboratoire,
ce phénomène est bel et bien possible,
et on peut étonnement faire bouillir de
l’eau, tout en la faisant simultanément geler.
Enfin, la remarque qui va le plus
nous intéresser sur ce diagramme,
est le fait que la courbe qui sépare l’étatliquide
de l’état gaz semble brusquements’arrêter.
Ce point bien particulier,
oùla courbe s’arrête, est appelé le point critique.
Il correspond à une température et unepression très élevées,
des conditions qui ne sont pas naturellement réunies sur Terre,
mais qu’onpeut infliger à une substance en laboratoire.
Reprenons notre récipient qui contientde l’eau,
et ajustons sa pression et sa température
de sorte à se placer sur cetteligne.
Comme on l’a vu, sur la courbe qui sépare les deux zones,
l’eau se manifeste
simultanément dans deux états différents,
en l'occurrence sous une phase liquide et unephase gazeuse.
Quand on observe le récipient,
on voit alors une séparationentre le liquide et le gaz.
On va maintenant chauffer
et progressivementcompresser le récipient,
de sorte à se rapprocher petit à petit du point critique,
mais tout enrestant sur la courbe.
Pas à pas, la pression dans le récipient augmente.
Les molécules d’eaudans le gaz sont ainsi fortement comprimées,
elles se rapprochent les unes des autres
etoccupent donc moins de place.
La vapeur d’eau devient de plus en plus dense.
D’autre part, latempérature en augmentant
va forcer les molécules
dans le liquide à s’agiter de plus en plusfort.
De cette façon, les molécules du liquide
sont de moins en moins liées entre elles,
et leuragitation toujours plus forte
les oblige à occuper davantage d’espace.
L’eau liquide devient doncde moins en moins dense.
La surface qui sépare le liquide de la vapeur
est alors de moins enmoins visible,
elle apparaît de plus en plus floue.
Quand soudain la densité du liquide,qui diminue,
et celle du gaz, qui augmente, atteignent la même valeur.
A partir de cemoment,
les deux phases ne sont plus distinctes,
le liquide et le gaz dans le récipient ont
désormais exactement la même densité.
On obtient une sorte de mélange
homogène du liquideet du gaz,
c’est ce point sur le diagramme qu’on appelle le point critique.
Au-delà de ce point,
il est impossible de distinguer le gaz du liquide,
les deux phases sont confondues,
elles ont enquelque sorte
fusionné pour n’en former plus qu’une seule.
L’état de l’eau dans le récipientn’est ni gazeux, ni liquide.
Elle se comporte de façon très similaire à un gaz,
mais elleprésente aussi certaines propriétés
troublantes, qui la rapprochent d’un liquide.
On dit quel’eau sous cet état est un fluide supercritique.
Premièrement, il est intéressant
denoter que contrairement à l’état solide,
les états liquides et gaz ne sont donc pasindépendants.
Bien qu’on puisse passer du liquide
au gaz par une transition de phase,
par exemple en faisant bouillir de l’eau,
il est également possible de passer d’unliquide
à un gaz sans jamais effectuerde transition.
Pour ce faire, il suffittout simplement d’ajuster progressivement
la température et la pression dans notrerécipient,
de sorte à contourner la courbe
qui sépare les deux états sur le diagramme.
En suivant ce procédé, on part d’un liquide,
et en passant par un fluide supercritique,on arrive à un gaz.
On appelle ce genre de procédé un “contournement du point triple”.
Cetteexpérience est impressionnante à observer,
car il est très inhabituel de voir un liquide devenirvapeur
sans qu’aucune transition ne soit visible.
Quand on s’approche progressivement
du pointcritique avec un fluide supercritique,
on peut observer un phénomène très étonnant.
Au momentd’atteindre son point critique,
le fluide se met naturellement à diffuser la lumière.
On appellece phénomène l’opalescence critique.
Ceci est dû à la réfraction de la lumière à l’intérieurdu fluide,
c’est-à-dire au ralentissement
des ondes lumineuses en fonction de sa densité.
Ense rapprochant du point critique,
le fluide va devoir se séparer en deux,
une phase liquide etune phase gazeuse.
Mais juste avant, tout se passe comme si
les molécules hésitaient entre une phaseet l’autre.
Ces sortes d’hésitations au sein du fluide
entraînent de très fortes fluctuationsde densité,
qui vont diffuser la lumière,
de la même façon que notre atmosphère
diffuse lalumière du Soleil pour donner sa couleur au ciel.
Dans notre quotidien, les fluidessupercritiques
sont utilisés pour denombreuses applications.
Leurs propriétéssont très intéressantes.
Notamment, bien qu’un tel fluide
se comporte principalementcomme un gaz,
il peut être utilisé comme solvant,
c’est-à-dire qu’il permet d’extraire certainessubstances.
On utilise notamment beaucoup
le dioxyde de carbone supercritique,
pour extrairedes arômes de plantes,
la nicotine du tabac, ou même retirer la caféine du café.
Un gros avantagedu CO2 supercritique
est que, contrairement aux autres solvants, liquides,
il n’est pas toxique,et est relativement simple et rapide à utiliser,
pour une puissance d’extraction très efficace.
Sous sa forme supercritique,
l’eau est également un très bon solvant.
Elle est très utile pourdétruire des déchets organiques,
sans pour autant dégager de gaz nocifs,
contrairement au cas oùon les brûlerait
Les fluides supercritiques sont utiles
pour une multitude d’applications diverseset variées,
comme la production de carburants,
pour des systèmes de réfrigération,
ou mêmepour leurs propriétés antimicrobiennes.
Pour conclure, le fluide supercritique
constitue à lui seul un état à part entière de la matière.
Au-delà d’une certaine
pression et d’une certaine température,
les phases liquide et gazeuses semblent fusionner,
elles ne forment plus qu’un seul état homogène,
qui possède à la fois des propriétés de gaz,
et des propriétés de liquide.
Sur Terre, les conditions de température et de pression
sont trop faibles pour permettre
l’existence de tels fluides à l’état naturel.
Il est tout demême possible d’en trouver de petites quantités,
mais seulement au fond des océans,
au sein decheminées hydrothermales,
là où la température et la pression
deviennent suffisamment extrêmes.
Mais s’il est rare sur Terre, l’état de fluide supercritique
est cependant relativement commundans l’univers,
et en particulier à l’intérieur des planètes gazeuses.
Dans leur atmosphère,
les conditions de pression et de température sont si extrêmes,
que certaines couches
degaz sont en fait supercritiques.
De même, l’atmosphère très chaude et très épaisse deVénus,
peut atteindre 500°C pour une pression
presque 100 fois plus élevée que sur Terre.
Sous de telles conditions, l’atmosphère presque
entièrement composée de dioxyde de carbone,
se manifeste comme un fluide supercritique.